M2 iPad Pro versus M2 MacBook Air how do
you choose well today we are going to
compare everything from the design the
ports the displays the speakers the
cameras and much more to help you make
the right choice now personally I'm
really curious about the performance of
the M2 Chip in an iPad and as you guys
can see here I have it on the magic
keyboard but the beauty of the iPad is
that you could take it off and you have
such a small and thin device that is
really powerful compared to the empty
MacBook gear which is also really nice
and small and lightweight but it still
does not compare to the dimensions and
the weight of this iPad the 12.9 inch
iPad is literally the same dimensions as
this lid but shorter and then you guys
saw that thickness there it is thinner
than even the bottom portion of the
MacBook of course it has those feet that
raise it off but with that if you go
ahead and add the keyboard case to to
make it a Macbook replacement well
obviously look at that it gets even
thicker than the MacBook and it is
actually heavier as well that is one
chunky keyboard and not only that it is
more expensive as well because this is a
350 keyboard the iPad by itself is at
least eleven hundred dollars and if you
match up the storage you're looking at a
thousand five hundred and fifty dollars
compared to twelve hundred and if you
want to make use of the apple pencil
well now you're up to almost Seventeen
hundred dollars so let's see if it's
worth spending that extra money now as
far as ports the Mt MacBook Air has two
Thunderbolt ports whereas the iPad has
one the MacBook also has a magsafe
charging port which is really nice but
if you buy the magic keyboard for the
iPad you do get additional USB type-c
port for charging now unfortunately that
Port doesn't charge as fast as plugging
into the iPad itself whereas the MacBook
it can actually charge to 50 percent in
less than 30 minutes compared to an hour
and a half and the MacBook can charge
fully in an hour and a half compared to
three hours for the iPad even though it
has a larger battery and we're gonna
talk about battery life in just a bit
now on the back of the iPad you guys see
that camera system which the MacBook
doesn't have and not only do we have a
standard camera we have an ultrawide
camera and we have a lidar sensor for
those that want to do scanning for
augmented reality all of that stuff and
that definitely adds to the cost but for
some people being able to have a camera
in the iPad built in could be very
useful now we also have some major
differences with the front cameras but
before we compare that if you're a Mac
User who does any sort of work with
documents spreadsheets or slideshows on
your Mac our sponsor software keep is
giving our viewers 20 off genuine
Microsoft software like a one-time
purchase of Microsoft Office for Mac
back which includes word excel and
PowerPoint now there are so many fishy
websites out there that could scam you
but software keep is a Microsoft
certified partner who only sells 100
genuine Microsoft software so you don't
have to worry which resulted in software
keep earning over a hundred thousand
five star reviews they also have great
prices on other software including the
most popular antivirus software out
there and their customer service is
phenomenal with 24 7 365 customer
support where you will talk to a real
person instead of a robot so if you have
any questions they'll be glad to help so
buy Microsoft Office for Mac or anything
else you need today and save 20 off
their already great prices by using the
link in the description and the coupon
code Max Tech 20. now as far as the
front cameras the MacBook has a normal
setup built in whereas the iPad it still
has the camera off to the side so when
you're on your keyboard I'm looking
straight at the display right now right
in the center and it looks like I'm not
paying attention do whoever I'm talking
to so uh that is definitely a downside
and as far as the microphones you guys
just go ahead and let me know which one
sounds better the MacBook or is it the
iPad now with that front-facing camera
we also have face ID so right there you
guys saw it instantly unlock me I'm
gonna tap again to get into uh iPad OS
and it's so quick and convenient and
with that you could also log you into
different apps uh to fill in your data
whereas with the MacBook even though we
have that Notch we do not have face ID
so it's just touch ID which isn't too
bad but not as convenient now before I
cover displays I want to talk about the
keyboards and the track pads the magic
keyboard is really nice the keys feel
better than any other tablet keyboard
the trackpad also works really well but
it is not as nice as an actual MacBook
and I think what a lot of people don't
talk about is when you have the iPad on
your lap it is not that balanced because
the iPad is really heavy so the whole
thing is top heavy and it bounces around
compared to the MacBook which is bottom
heavy so it is nice and stable so
overall if you're using it on your lap
the MacBook experience is definitely
better and with that the magic keyboard
does not have a function row so if you
want to do things like adjust your
brightness skip songs you're switching
to the display to do those kind of
things whereas the MacBook we have that
full function row key it's very
convenient now hopefully in the future
Apple will update this keyboard like
their new folio which does have that but
for now we are stuck with this on the
plus side we also have the apple pencil
for the iPad which you can't get on a
Mac it attaches and charges and pairs
automatically at the top there and you
can do things like writing quick notes
you can draw with it but as you guys see
even my handwriting sucks so I don't
really use it for that but for some
people the apple pencil and the ability
to have a touch screen is is worth it
alone to go for an iPad getting into
displays the actual detail and sharpness
isn't much different but the iPad has
120 hertz Pro motion so everything is
super smooth as you guys could see in
the slow motion shot now we also have a
big difference in brightness and
manually upping both of these to the
maximum you can see that the iPad is a
little bit brighter it's 600 nits
compared to 500 the viewing angles of
the iPad is also a lot better than the
MacBook but when you're watching HDR
content the iPad looks much better
because it's using a mini LED display so
it can reach up to 1600 nits compared to
just 500 so video really pops and if
you're watching in a darker environment
the difference is absolutely massive
because you have almost pure black
levels like an OLED compared to the LCD
in the MacBook which has gray everywhere
so the movie watching experience is much
better with the iPad now with mini LED
you can get blooming sometimes if it's
turned up Max on brightness and it's
pure white on black but the MacBook has
blooming everywhere because the LCD is
making everything bright so when I'm at
home or I go somewhere and I want to
watch a movie I'm planning for that I
definitely want to take the iPad now
with that we also have a difference in
speakers the iPad has quad speakers it
has woofers and tweeters all around
compared to speakers that are built in
and hidden inside of the case itself
with no speaker holes so with that let's
go ahead and compare the speaker quality
and let's take a listen
bring me back
[Music]
now Apple advertised the MacBook speaker
system that it has woofers and tweeters
built in but the iPad sounds so much
better in the mids you have way more
bass it's louder better Clarity and not
only that but when you're watching one
thing you guys can't hear online is the
separation if you're watching a movie
the speakers are on the sides so the
whole sound is surrounding you it just
it is such a great experience watching
something or listening compared to the
MacBook where a lot of the sound is
coming from right here in the center
where the speakers are packed so as far
as audio it is way better on the iPad
and now let's get into the performance
starting out with our disc speed test
I'm going to run blackmagics here and
jaspy test here now the base MacBook Air
only comes with a single Nan chip which
makes the storage slower and we have a
right speed difference of 1421 compared
to 953 now this is the 128 gigabyte
version of the iPad Pro but the 256 gig
version is 2
124. that's getting near twice as fast
as the MacBook in terms of the read
speeds we have 1443 compared to 1570 so
even the 128 gig is faster but the 256
comes in at
3240 much much faster now the internal
speed is just one aspect what about real
world transfers both of these do have
Thunderbolt ports so you think they
would be the same but I tested out
transferring a 24.6 gig file and it took
36 seconds on the iPad compared to just
16 seconds on the MacBook now if you
think that's just because the slow ride
speed of the 128 gig well you would be
wrong because even the 256 gig model
took about the same time 37 seconds and
that is because for some reason the
Thunderbolt port in the iPad is nowhere
near as fast for data transfers compare
here to even a base MacBook we had this
issue with the M1 iPad Pro and I was
hoping it'd be fixed but nope the M2
still does the same thing now as far as
web performance I'm going to run
speedometer 2.0 right here and a test
loading JavaScript web-based apps things
like that and as you guys can see both
of these are incredibly fast faster than
anything else uh the iPad 1 by a little
bit doesn't really matter but in terms
of how it feels because of the promotion
it does feel a little bit snappier now
in terms of the M2 Chip performance I'm
going to go ahead and run geekbench
right here to see the performance some
people are worried about the M2 Chip
being slowed down in a such a thin
tablet and both these do have eight gigs
of RAM now the MacBook you can actually
get up to 24 gigabytes but more
importantly you could say with the lower
amount of storage and still bump up to
16 whereas with the iPad you have to buy
at least a terabyte to get 16 gigs and
you're paying extra for the 16 so Apple
locks it down or in turn forces you to
get 16 gigs when you might not want it
or need it with iPad OS if you want a
terabyte we have our performance
resolved and the MacBook beat up the
iPad by a little bit in terms of single
core and multi-core performance but it
is very minor now as far as graphics
performance I'm going to run our metal
compute test which tests a lot of
different things and looking at the
results the iPad is actually faster with
its M2 Chip and that is because apple
does not bin the 10 core graphics for
the iPad whereas with the MacBook you
have to pay extra to get that or it just
comes with an 8 Graphics core M2 Chip
which is about 25 slower now in terms of
gaming performance I'm going to run 3D
Marks Wildlife extreme test in the
unlimited mode and looking at the
results the iPad even though you might
think it just will Throttle Down in such
a thin body it's still about 22 percent
faster in terms of frame rates now I ran
this multiple times here and after
you've been gaming for about 15 to 20
minutes the iPad will slow down almost
to the performance of the MacBook after
it made multiple runs so the MacBook
actually throttles faster almost right
away whereas the iPad gives you a little
bit more oomph and then that goes away
so they didn't really need to give it
that extra Graphics at least for a
longer kind of renders now I don't just
want to run those benchmarks I want to
run something real world and a lot of
people love doing photo editing on the
iPad it's great with the apple pencil
you have a lot of control but I'm
curious about the performance here I
have 50 42 megapixel of raw files I have
edits on all of the images here and
snappiness they are both great so I'm
going to go ahead and Export these I'm
gonna start my timer right here and I'm
using Lightroom Mobile on both of these
so same software same chip we just have
iPad OS versus Mac OS that the MacBook
hit 108 degrees Celsius almost right
away and now it is throttling down to
103 104 but it is still exporting faster
than the iPad bam we are done here
actually I have to save first and
without counting that saving the iPad
took 2 minutes and 58 seconds compared
to two minutes flat on the Macbook so
the MacBook is 50 faster even though
everything else is the same and I
noticed that across a few different apps
testing Mac OS compared to iPad
previously where Mac OS is just faster
and that brings me to the whole
operating system with Mac OS you can run
a lot of iPad apps but you have full
access to say the full version like
Lightroom classic which is even faster
than this mobile version with iPad OS we
have the full app store that has a ton
of apps that are there you have great
media apps you have good apps for
productivity we have procreate there
there's just an insane library of
different things you could do for
example you have some video editing
applications and they are all very
inexpensive compared to a lot of Mac
apps which you'll spend a lot more money
on but it's worth it for example Final
Cut you get the full version DaVinci
Resolve as well now that's going to come
to the iPad soon but it is a minor cut
down version still not the full thing so
as far as applications it's hit or miss
you have more stuff for the iPad but
more powerful things for Mac OS and then
with that multitasking we still don't
have full multitasking for the iPad now
Apple did add stage manager where you
can bring apps together you have a lot
more control and scalability we have
that sidebar you can stretch stuff in
and then you can pull out that sidebar
and have different pairs of apps so it
is a nice update but you don't have full
control like you do with the Mac where
you can have Windows however you want
you are not limited so over overall I
just wish the Apple would add Mac OS to
the iPad instead of limited us with you
know this regular view of AD before or
stage manager it would just open up so
much possibilities it would make this
truly a pro device with that the files
app still has issues there's still no
way to eject a hard drive so in the
previous test when I was testing out the
transfer speeds even though I was so
careful it still corrupt my SSD I have
to use a Mac to repair it and people
have been complaining about this kind of
stuff for such a long time but if Apple
added Mac OS here well you wouldn't have
to buy a Mac and an iPad you could just
buy an iPad you could see how powerful
it is but at this point iPad OS is still
limiting and now let's talk about the
battery life the MacBook has a battery
that's about 27 larger than the iPad and
with that the iPad screen gets much
brighter and it also supports Pro motion
now Apple's battery life figures are
very vague but if you're doing very
light tasks with the iPad you can get up
to 10 hours compared to about 15 on the
MacBook but if you're pushing both
machines for example photo editing and
you're raising up that brightness people
have said they get as low as four hours
for the iPad compared to eight hours for
the MacBook because that screen doesn't
dry anywhere near as much power so the
battery life difference can be pretty
massive and with that the MacBook
charges twice as fast as the iPad if
you're using a faster charger for both
devices so it's definitely a big win for
the MacBook in terms of battery life so
with all of that said should you buy one
of these M2 iPads or just get an Mt
MacBook Air well it is still a very
tough choice and if you know that you
want the apple pencil you want the rear
cameras you want to be able to hold it
in your hand like this it's obvious you
get the iPad but if you're mostly using
your machine like you would a laptop and
you want the iPad to be a laptop
replacement well I personally prefer to
have a Macbook most of the time even
though the display is not as good the
speakers aren't as good it's just very
convenient the form factor the weight
balance it's not wobbling it's a lot
less expensive and you have full Mac OS
which is a huge selling point so for me
as long as I'm not watching a bunch of
media and music and movies I'd rather
have the MacBook and save some money but
if you want the app library from the App
Store and some of those other things the
iPad is a good choice you'll just be
limited to when you want to use it as a
Macbook replacement if only Apple would
fix the software but of course they
don't want to let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below click
that Circle above to subscribe to see
more videos like this one and check out
one of those great videos right over
there the spnax and I'll see you in the
next one
foreign